what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are covering the story where
the flash Wally West out runs the
universe it's insane and this is
actually a story called the human race
now this story was written by Grant
Morrison and when it comes to the flash
line of stories there have been a
handful of writers over the years after
crisis on Infinite Earths in 1985 Wally
West became the new flash is that what
you had was you had like Mike Barron
then you had Bill Loeb then you had Mark
Waid who wrote it for a number of years
and then there was a point where mark
mark weight took a break and what you
had was like Grant Morrison who wrote it
for a little while and then Mark Waid
came back for a brief time and then it
was taken over by geoff johns but the
whole idea with rant Morrison's
storytelling it usually follows the form
and function of I want to tell a story
that has like a greater purpose it's
basically a commentary on the nature of
people or something along those lines
and if the characters have powers that's
cool and if they don't have powers
that's cool but I'll just use them
however I want to and so this is one of
those stories that's told we're really
like elevated the speed of the flash in
the sense that like you know Mike Baron
and Bill Loeb
Mark Waid those guys focus on like the
character of Wally West breaking out of
the shadow of Barry Allen different
things like that how a speed worked
inventing the Speed Force to man things
along those lines
Grant Morrison's the human race was just
let's see how fast we can make the flash
go and that's basically what this is
this is I would argue probably the
fastest point the flash any version of
the flash has ever traveled in the
history of DC Comics having said that
what this does is it initially picks up
with really just like the arrival of a
guy a guy who's really just kind of
dying and he's referred to as g-force or
at least he calls himself to you force
now Wally West showing up here you know
he's basically met by the arrival or at
Lisa he shows up when there's already
like Linda Park and the police and
Everett things like that now but what is
up happening is that with the arrival of
g-force and him basically kind of
collapsing we basically end up having
like the arrival of these giant robots
more or less these giant machines and
all they really say is that we are
beings that gamble and basically you run
we gamble that's it and that's the whole
basis behind this it's basically this
idea that this group travels around the
cosmos and basically initiates this
gigantic race this race among the
fastest beings in existence and what
they do is they effectively tell the
entire denizens of Earth the entire
citizenry you have 24 hours to pick your
fastest person and that person is going
to engage in a race if that person loses
the
or if that person refuses to race your
planet will be destroyed if that person
wins your planet will be spared now
there is a caveat to it and we'll cover
that a little bit more here in a second
but it is really intriguing because what
this does is it immediately hits on the
idea that the flash is the fastest man
alive and that's just the way it is and
that was the nature that's one of the
things they say here is that g-force the
person who arrived here had basically
failed and his planet was totally
incinerated in its entirety and so they
essentially say that's the fate that
awaits you now from here it's exactly
what we would expect a meeting with the
Justice League of America but remember
this is kind of intriguing because this
is the era of blue and red Superman more
or less we don't really have to get into
that it's weird it was basically DC's
attempt to try to like reinvigorate the
Superman concept following his death in
return it didn't really do too well
people didn't really enjoy it too much
for the most part they want a classic
Superman which is what we got we
originally got classic Superman back but
you know the man of energy was kind of
intriguing but the fact remains Grant
Morrison really plays it close to the
vest when it's like the rolls superhero
plays you know the the flash is
predicated on the notion of being the
fastest man alive
ergo if Grant Morrison's writing the
story were it's basically a race with
the fastest person on earth it has to be
the flash and so that's what ends up
happening here basically Wally West
signs up and says okay the entirety of
Earth chooses Wally West and he
immediately races off travels through
this portal and meets his opponent and
so what we end up finding out is that
the opponent of of Wally West is
actually kind of a fictional friend or
at least it seemed to be an imaginary
friend he had when he was younger what
we end up finding out is this imaginary
friend was actually real now this friend
that Wally has and it's really kind of
interesting is basically a being made
out of radio waves and it's a being
simply called crackle but the funny
thing about this is that what it does is
it essentially says back when Wally was
a kid before he got his powers he had a
radio that he would talk into and he
would get a response from that radio and
basically the person on the other end
who he believed to be fiction and are
fictional would basically tell them
about like radio land this place where
there's like you know radio waves and
things that are made of radio waves and
all kinds of cool stuff because it kind
of fed into Wally West's love of like
the radio industry and how radios worked
and different things like that the long
and short of this is that crackle
essentially explains that it's raced
against six different opponents and it's
won every time I'm sorry a quiz rather
has ray a waste raced against six
different opponents and won every time
and so the question becomes how in the
world can Wally West
when facing off against an opponent
that's defeated six other people and so
this is when we find out the nature of
the race it's not like you know some
race where they just kind of run across
from like Earth to Mars or something
like that
they're running throughout the entire
you know space-time continuum they're
effectively running across the universe
and they're transitioning into all these
different planes and different things
like that but it's insane because when
this race kicks off what ends up
happening is the first challenge
quote-unquote they have to face is
basically a black hole and this is a
pretty big deal because when it comes to
black holes one of the things that DC
kind of keeps intact is the physical
properties of a black hole in the real
world in the sense that the
gravitational pull is so extreme that
light can't escape I mean you know the
end of the day of black hole is just a
collapse dead start the long and short
of this is that when it comes to the
flash there's basically I guess the
speed of light is kind of like the upper
limit I mean a flash can travel faster
than the speed of light but when they do
they risk entering the speed force and
that's the concern that Wally West has
because light cannot escape a black hole
if he runs at a speed that basically
exceeds the speed of light in order to
get past in order to basically make his
way you know around this black hole then
what it means is that he could
potentially enter the speed force now
remember the way that this is done by
Grant Morrison and even the way it was
kind of done by Mark Waid as a speedster
can't really choose to enter the Speed
Force I mean they kind of can't but in
the instance if they're kind of brushing
up against it like you're running
alongside a brick wall the Speed Force
will grab them and drag them in even if
they don't want to be there and that's
exactly what happens to Wally as he's
running he's basically approaching this
massive amount of energy basically the
source of where he draws his speed from
and it immediately starts to pull him in
and so where it seems as though he's
basically lost to the Speed Force one is
up happening is we basically have like
quiz that reaches in and grabs him
because he's made of radio waves now in
truth and historically speaking this
shouldn't be the case a person who's not
a speedster can't just enter into the
Speed Force meaning a person who doesn't
draw their energy from the Speed Force
can't necessarily enter the Speed Force
you know the Speed Force is like a giant
door and the only people who had the key
to that door are speedsters is so
technically speaking as far as I'm aware
quiz shouldn't be able to just like
reach into the Speed Force and grab
Wally but because of the fact that he
does he also merely ends up saving and
yanking him out and they end up in like
the distant past eons and eons billions
of years into the past in the early days
of the Mount
now of course we know the Malthusians
basically go on to become the guardians
of the universe but because of the fact
that that Malthusians are effectively
the first sentient beings in the
universe what this meant is that we are
talking about you know probably around
seven or eight billion years in the past
and that's the nature of things keep in
mind when it comes to like you know the
space-time continuum
they're not separate you know space is
not separate from time you know for
example you have the idea I think it's
what is a special theory of relativity
the speed of an object is relative to
the speed of light and then general
theory of relativity the speed of object
is relative to the speed of light and
the the impact of everything around it
that you know space and when it comes to
like you know earth for example if I
were to take a giant piece of paper
towel and I were to sit the earth on it
or sit like a giant golf ball on it or
something like that it would cause an
indentation in that paper towel that's
how your planets and stars impact space
it's more of a fabric than an actual
like finite structure and so because of
that when an object has enough has
enough force to get pulling things
around or enough gravity they could pull
an objects around at different things
like that and that's the nature of this
whole thing that's the nature of this
whole scenario it's kind of you know
running back and forth through time the
fact that you can't you know travel
through time without traveling through
space different things like that it gets
kind of weird and it gets kind of you
know metaphysically but the fact remains
here that what is up happening is that
with this spanning over the course of
about four or five days but basically
it's kind of Grant Morrison skipping
over things in the sense that you end up
having like quiz in the end having Wally
West who continued their race they kind
of race closer to the modern day quizzes
of outracing Wally West gets way ahead
different things like that but it is
kind of wild and it's kind of intriguing
because there's one point where it's day
eight and Wally West is running
continually to the present day from the
distant past and he actually ends up
coming it or at least running through
Krypton at the point where it's
exploding which is about thirty years
before the modern day now I do want to
talk about this for a second when it
comes to DC Comics for years and years
and years there was no real timeline
given in terms of when things happen it
was just somewhere along the line
Krypton exploded somewhere along the
line Superman landed on earth
somewhere along the line Bruce Wayne
became Batman that was really yet it was
there was never really like a
chronological order of things in terms
of DC saying here's what it all happened
all this changed in 1993 with zero our
crisis and time and what DC did is they
basically completed that massive event
and then gave us a timeline they said
like you know ten years ago Superman
arrived on earth ten years ago Bruce
Wayne became Batman
and so that's why we get this 30 year
window that's what was established in
zero our crisis in time thirty years ago
Krypton blew up and so it is kind of
interesting in terms of like how it ties
in to the greater DC landscape but the
fact remains that with Wally kind of
racing as fast as he can this is when we
find out kind of like the darker side of
the race the way this is done is that if
you win let's say for example that Wally
West wins this race what it would mean
is that the planet of quiz would be
totally obliterated and then Wally would
have to race again and he would have to
keep on racing until he lost and when he
lost earth would be destroyed and the
new winner would be forced to race a
continue to race until they fail and
then the their planet is destroyed and a
new winner is chosen and so that's how
this whole thing works that Wally's kind
of facing this almost no-win situation
in the sense that there's no real
conceivable way for him to be able to
succeed ultimately he and earth are
going to be destroyed in this great race
that goes on and so what we end up
having is Wally finally catching up to
quizzed on this kind of a pit stop that
has been set up in different locations
around the cosmos and what is up
happening here it's quiz basically says
the reason he was able to defeat the six
other opponents was not purely based on
his speed alone but what we end up
finding out is that the energy of a
person's home planet which is to say the
kinetic energy put off by the citizens
of a home planet running can basically
be siphoned off by oh by Wally West and
then used to bolster his own speed and
so this is cool this is when it gets
into the meta commentary of Grant
Morrison because what Grant Morrison
basically says is sure the earth has all
kinds of problems but at the end of the
day everybody wants to live and so
because of that when Wally West just
kind of uses the intercom has been
that's been attached to him that allows
him to continually communicate with
earth instantaneously what this means is
it allows him to effectively tell
everybody on earth everyone has to run
you are you know every single human
being out there every person regardless
of where you come from regardless of how
old you are if you can run you have to
run because I can siphon off your energy
and I can ensure the survival of our of
our species by basically winning the
race and beating quiz this is kind of
cool because the other half of this is
that Wally has a genius idea Wally sits
down with these guys and says okay so
you guys bet the whole basis of this is
that you guys do this to gamble and so
the response of Wally is here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna start a new
bet I will race you all the way back to
earth and if I get there before you do
you have to spare my planet and it's
kind of cool because what this means is
that Wally West is going to travel
so astronomically fast millions of miles
in less than an instant and that's one
thing I want you guys to keep in mind
here and this next little bit that we go
over all this happens in the fashions of
a second you can't even measure it snap
your fingers right now and this race
happens in less time than that it's
insane the issue with this is that while
they can't necessarily do it on its own
because of the fact you know with
everybody out there racing with
everybody running it's still not
necessarily fast or enough energy for
him to basically siphon it off and make
it back to earth so one is up happening
is quiz actually throws his power to
Wally West and sacrifices his life in
the process but what it does is it
doubles the speed of Wally West in
response to this what also is up
happening is Superman Jay Garrick
impulse max mercury you know these
various speedsters who were out there
also run as fast as they can
bolstering the power of Wally even more
and so in truth it's not really just
Wally speed on its own that allows him
to achieve this insane amount of
distance in such a short amount of time
it's really him kind of feeding on the
speed of everybody else around him but
remember this works because one of the
big changes that was made to the
character of Wally West one of the big
things that was established with him is
that unlike other speedsters he can both
gift his speed to other people and take
his speed away now other people have
been given that power over the years but
Wally was the first one to do it
and so with Wally being able to you know
siphon off the speed of others or gift
others his a fraction of his own speed
he basically draws on all this energy
that's being sent directly into him and
not only makes it back to earth before
one of these you know gambling guys does
he makes it back to earth and actually
manages to make his way around Jay
Garrick and Superman about a million
times before they get here in so it's
insane because what is happening is we
end up also finding out that with Wally
West making this race what he also did
is he grabbed as citizens of Wiz's
people and brought them to earth and so
effectively the plant is gonna be
destroyed or the planet is completely
uninhabited it doesn't matter and so the
earth of Wally West has been totally
saved not only that he's basically saved
this this race of people and then of
course gives them a chance to basically
find their own world find a place they
can go off to or just reside on earth or
something along those lines but it's
pretty wild and it's pretty insane
because it's a crazy amount of speed so
effectively Wally's kind of hailed as
like this Savior of the year our Saviour
of Earth more or less if he's a being
who essentially saved everybody in
existence and so though the way this
kind of
works when they come to Grant Morrison
stories what would it be without like a
you know a plot twist or something along
those lines
what is up happening is wall-e you know
basically speaking to a class and
talking about the nature of what it
means to try to save the world and how
you always have to kind of persevere and
keep on going he takes a picture with
the class but when the picture is
finished and the people look at it what
we end up finding out is in the
background of this picture is the black
flash watching Wally West but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explain it make sure you guys
at the sub button - become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later please
[Music]